all right mariah
yes mariah where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um
san pedro california south of l.a yes
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were a kid
no i had my my mom
my biological dad he
he left my mom when she was pregnant
with me
so i don't have no
i don't know who he is my stepdad came
into my life when i was two
but even then my grandmother's my mom's
mom still raised me as
her child
so your grandmother my grandmother took
care of her kids kids
because they were too young too and how
would you describe your childhood
difficult um
dysfunctional abusive what kind of abuse
physical verbal emotional
everything but sexual
were you transgender or gay or something
like that early on in your life
i was but i didn't know what it was or
how to identify
as as it but did it cause problems does
people pick on you or anything like that
i was different so kids in school
of course they make fun of it talk about
phagesis and gazes and but it really
didn't bother me then
and it wasn't until i found out who i
was at the age of 11
that i wanted to
be a trans woman
and then that
put separation between me and some of my
family members
my mom especially
so you didn't feel very accepted no they
weren't as a kid
and how were your high school years
you know as um we got older all the kids
i went to school
with in elementary school from
kindergarten on earth or it's basically
the same kids i went to school with
throughout the rest of my um
middle middle school high school
and they got used to me
they knew who i was so they didn't
have the judgmental walls that didn't
yeah they got they got to know me so you
had some
real friends as a kid that's great
and then where'd your life go after you
left the school
well i supposed to go into the military
and that didn't pay out well because i
didn't show up for boot camp
because it was um being a military brat
it's um always been my family's
legacies and things to join some branch
of the military
so your friend you felt pressure to do
that i did
and when my grandmother and my mom
finally agreed on something
that was one thing and so to show them
that i could do it
i went and scored one of the highest
scores on the as lab tests
possible i got sworn in
was scheduled to leave september 5th of
2000 to go to boot camp
after i graduated high school
i just didn't i chose a different path i
chose one for me not for
what my family wanted me to be
and where'd you go from there
well let's same year my grandmother
passed away
and that was like my rock that was the
person that
i turned to confined it in for
everything
after she left i didn't have nobody
trusted to turn to
so
i moved out to hollywood
and my roommate there
he's like he was a gang member
but for a side hustle he went and sold
his male penis part
to older dudes
and um he was getting high on crystal
meth
and it wasn't until my grandmother
passed away december 1st of 2000
i found out december 15th the first line
of
crystal i snorted was on december 16th
of 2000.
are you still using it today no
what are you using today
okay great that's it contact leave
no drugs um what are you doing for money
now
um there's a couple things one
is my um
[Music]
they've been home caretaker from my
cousin
and i have a side fun
that's some understood understood
and your
little side hustle that you do is that
uh
is that problematic at times
um
it can be
but it's not like i'm i
some people have to be out there doing
whatever it takes
to survive
i just like sometimes going for shows at
night and i'm sorry
i like going for walks at night yeah and
i'm sure when you go for a walk at night
you get lots of attention i do
and [ __ ]
i am grown
you are grown you're free to do whatever
you want
yes you've been arrested though
no never never because technically that
kind of work is illegal
yes because you're not paying taxes on
it that's one of the reasons yes
what's the create what's the craziest
thing one of your
boyfriends has asked you to do and they
pick you up
and there's been quite a few i've had
some with feet fetishes i've had some
with
wanting to be dominated
and they've even wanted to be urinated
on
it's like yeah
there are these guys that are
but these are like well-established men
who live like in hollywood hills and
stuff like that
are they married sometimes you think yes
most of the guys that i have come across
they've always they've been married
they're on the down low
yeah you can say that or it's just
something that
they haven't been able to talk with
their partner about that they have
tendencies of wanting to experiment with
this and do with this
and their partners aren't able to
understand that it's not taking away
from
how they really feel about them this is
the other part
that's not being satisfied
yeah it's an interesting world out there
isn't it it is
it's dependent
what emotions do you deal with most you
get depressed sometimes do you get uh
angry um no
i try to it's hard to make me angry
but i do with um
depression
failure failing
um
i'm struggling to make everybody else
happy
and to try to do what
i feel is what they believe is what's
right
do you feel misunderstood especially by
your family
not no more i did it one time
but my mom
has come to acceptance
we have a mutual agreement where
as long as it's just the immediate
family which would be consists of
my my gut my stepdad my mom my sister
her husband
they could call me whatever they want to
call me in
around them but if we're out in the
public
and you call me anything outside of
your daughter or my name
that i choose to be called i'm not
answering you
so don't take it personally if i wanted
to
and so they they accept that one
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
to put pride and ego aside
and know when to ask for help when i
need it
instead of trying to i want to put my
burdens on others and
act like i got it what's most
misunderstood about your your lifestyle
one night it's a choice
and i understand both
sides of that yes it's a choice to
choose to
whatever clothes you're going to put on
that day
but it's not your choice of who you
identify who you
identify with as a person that's a
battle that we
struggle with daily trying to
get
seen as who we truly feel we are
have you been in love before have you
been in love before
yes a couple of times
would you describe yourself as happy am
i happy now
generally yeah
what's the hardest part of living this
lifestyle
um ignorances people's ignorances
and unwilling
they want to be accepted for who and
what they are
and whatever lifestyle choices they
choose to make
but they can't offer that same in return
to the next person
what advice would you give to a young
person going through what you went
through
stay strong stay believe in yourself
because it doesn't matter what anybody
else
thinks or believes that's how you really
believe in yourself
excellent so mariah thank you so much
for sharing your story
you're welcome i wish you the best of
luck out there thank you
thank you
you